The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we're ready for
the second lecture today.
We will start to get into a
little technical material,
which doesn't mean necessarily
that it's more important.
It just means that it's easier
because it deals with
mathematics.
I'm going to spend a little
bit more time reviewing
probability, as you
learned it before.
I want to review it at a
slightly more fundamental
level than what you're
used to seeing it as.
You will understand why as we go
on because when we get into
stochastic processes, we will
find that there are lots of
very peculiar things
that happen.
And when peculiar things happen,
the only thing you can
do is go back to basics ideas.
And if you don't understand what
those basic ideas are,
then you're in real trouble.
So we'll start out by talking
about expectations just a
little bit.
Distribution function of a
random variable often says
more than you're really
interested in.
In other words, a distribution
function is a function from
the whole sample space into
the real numbers.
And that's a very complicated
thing in general.
And the expectation is just
one simple number.
And with that one simple number,
you get an idea of
what that random variable is all
about, whether it's big or
it's little or what have you.
They're a bunch of formulas that
you're familiar with for
finding the expectation.
If you have a discrete random
variable, the usual formula is
you take all of the possible
sample values, multiply each
of them by the probability
of that sample value,
and you sum it up.
This is what you learned right
at the beginning of taking
probability.
If you've never taken
probability, you learned it in
statistic classes just as
something you don't know where
it comes from.
But it's there.
If you have a continuous random
variable, a continuous
random variable is one
that has a density.
You can find the expectation
there.
If you have an arbitrary random
variable and it's not
negative, then there's this
peculiar formula here, which I
will point to.
I think I'll point to it.
Ah yes, I will point to it.
This formula down here, you
might or might not have seen.
And I hope by the end of this
course, you'll realize that
it's one, more fundamental and
two, probably more useful than
either of these two.
And then there's a final one,
which this final formula, I'll
tell you a little bit about
that when we get to it.
OK, the formula for the expected
value in terms of the
integral of the complimentary
distribution function.
There's a picture here which
shows you how it corresponds
to the usual thing you're
used to for a
discrete random variable.
Namely what you're doing is
you're integrating this
complimentary distribution
function, which is the
probability that the random
variable x is greater than any
particular x along
the axis here.
So you integrate this
function along here.
And according to what I'm trying
to convince you of,
just integrating that function
gives you the expected value.
And the reason is that this top
little square here is a1
times the probability that
x is equal to a1.
Next one is a2 times the
probability it's equal to a2
and so forth down.
And you can obviously generalize
this to any
discrete random variable,
which is non-negative.
And I'm just talking about
non-negative random variables
for the moment.
If x has a density, the same
argument applies to any
Riemann sum for that integral.
You can take integrals.
You can break them up
into little slices.
If you break them up into
little slices, you can
represent it in this way.
And presto, again, you get that
this integral is equal to
the expectation.
And if you have any other thing
at all, you can always
represent it in terms
of this Riemann sum.
Now why is it even more
powerful then that?
Well, it's more powerful then
that because if you took
measure theory--
which most of you presumably
have not taken yet, and many
of you might never take it--
you will find out that this
is really the fundamental
definition after all.
And integration, when you look
and measure theoretic terms,
instead of taking little slices
that go this way, you
wind up taking little slices
that go that way.
So that any way this is the
fundamental definition of
expectation.
If you're worried about whether
expectations exist or
not, why is this much nicer?
Because what you're integrating
here is simply a
function, which is monotonic
decreasing with x.
In other words, if you try to
integrate it by integrating
this function out to some
largest value and then
chopping if off there, what
you get is some number.
If you extend this chopping off
point out, what you get is
a number which keeps
increasing.
What can happen?
As you take a number which is
increasing, you either get to
infinity or you get to
some finite limit.
Nothing else can happen.
So there aren't any limiting
problems here.
And when you take expectations
in other ways, there are
always questions that
you have to ask.
And they're often serious.
So this is just a much nicer
way of doing it.
Anyway, that's the way
we're going to do it.
And so now we go on.
Oh, I should mention where the
other formula comes from.
This formula back here.
You get that by representing x
as both the positive part of x
plus the negative part of x.
And if you want to see how to
do that exactly, it's in the
notes where it talks about
first this and then this.
So you just put the
two together.
And then you get an
expected value.
A word about notation here, and
there's nothing I can do
about this.
It's an unfortunate thing.
When somebody says that the
expected value of a random
variable exists, what
do they mean?
Any engineer would try to
integrate it and would either
get something which was
undefined, because it was
infinite going this way.
It's minus infinity
going that way.
And there's no way to put
the two together.
If you get infinity going this
way, something finite going
that way, like with a
non-negative random variable,
it's kind of silly to say the
expectation doesn't exist.
Because really what's happening
is the expectation
is infinite.
Now mathematicians and everybody
who writes books,
everybody who writes
papers, everybody--
I think--
defines expected value as
existing only if it's finite.
In other words, what you're
doing is taking this integral
over the set of real values.
And you don't allow plus
infinity or minus infinity.
So you say that the expectation
does not exist if
in fact it's infinite or it's
minus infinity or it is
undefined completely.
And you say it's undefined
in all of those cases.
And that's just a convention
that everybody lives by.
So the other way of saying this
is if the expected value
of the magnitude of the random
variable is infinite, then the
expectation doesn't exist.
So we will try to say it
that way sometimes
when it's really important.
OK, let's go on to indicator
random variables.
You're probably familiar
with these.
For every event you can think
of, an event is something
which is true, which occurs when
some set of the sample
points occur and is not
true otherwise.
So the definition of an
indicator random variable is
that the indicator
for an event a--
as a function of the
sample space--
is equal to 1, if omega is in
the event a, and 0 otherwise.
So if you draw the distribution
function of it,
the distribution function of the
indicator function is 0 up
until the point 0.
Then it jumps up to 1 minus
the probability of a.
At 1, it jumps all
the way up to 1.
So it's simply a binary
random variable.
So every event has an indicator
Every indicator random
variable has a
binary random variable.
So indicator random variables
are very simple.
Events are very simple because
you can map any event into an
indicator random variable
[INAUDIBLE].
And this also says that since
we want to talk about events
very often, binary random
variables are particularly
important in this field.
OK, but what this really says
now is that any theorem about
random variables can be
applied to events.
This is one of the few examples
I know where it's
much harder to find the
expectation by taking the
complimentary distribution
function and integrating it.
It's not hard.
But it's far easier to take
the probability that the
indicator random variable
is 0, which is 1 minus
probability of a.
The probability is equal to 1,
which is probability of a, and
take the expectation, which is
the probability of a, and the
standard deviation, which
is the square root the
probability of a times 1 minus
the probability of a.
So random variables are sort
of trivial things in a way.
OK, let's go on to multiple
random variables.
Now here's something that's
a trick question in a way.
But it's a very important
trick question.
Is a random variable specified
by its distribution function?
We've already seen that it's
not really specified by its
density or by its probability
mass function.
But we've said a distribution
function is a more general
thing so that every random
variable has a
distribution function.
Does the distribution function
specify the random variable?
No, that's the whole
reason for what
Kolmogorov did back in 1933.
Or at least it was one
of the main reasons
for what he was doing.
He wanted to straighten out
this ambiguity which runs
through the field about
confusing random variables
with their distribution
function.
Random variables are functions
from the sample space to the
real numbers.
And they're not anything else.
So if you want to really define
a random variable, you
not only have to know what that
random variable is but
you also have to know what
its relationships are.
It's like if you're trying
to understand the person.
You can't understand the person
without understanding
something about who they know,
how they know them, all those
other things.
All those relationships
are important.
And it's the same with
random variables.
You got to know about all
the relationships.
Many problems you can solve
just in terms of
distribution function.
But ultimately you have to--
or ultimately in many cases,
you have to deal with these
joint distribution functions.
And random variables
are independent.
If the joint distribution
function is equal to the
product of the distribution
functions for all x1 to xn,
and that same form carries over
for density functions and
for probability mass
functions.
OK, if you have discrete random
variables, the idea of
independence is a whole lot more
intuitive if you express
it in terms of conditional
probabilities.
The conditional probability
that the random variable x
takes on some sample value x
given that the random variable
y takes on a sample value y.
Just as one side comment here,
when you're doing problems,
you will very often want to
leave out the subscripts here
saying what random variables
you're dealing with.
And you will use either capital
or small letters here
mixing up the argument and the
function itself, which
everybody does.
And it's perfectly all right.
I suggest that you try not to do
it for a while because you
get so confused doing this,
not being able to sort out
what's a random variable and
what's a real number.
A lot of wags say random
variables are neither random,
because they're functions
of the sample space,
nor are they variables.
And both of those are true.
That's immaterial here.
It's just that when you start
getting confused about a
problem, it's important to
sort out which things are
random variables and which
things are arguments.
Now this conditional probability
is something
you're all familiar with.
But x and y are independent then
if the probability of x
conditional on y is the same
as the probability of x not
conditional on y.
In other words, if observing
what y is doesn't tell you
anything about what x is, that's
really your intuitive
definition of independence.
It's what you use if
you're dealing with
some real world situation.
And you're asking what does
this have to do with that?
And if this has nothing to
do with that, the random
variables over here have nothing
to do with the random
variables over there, you would
say in the real world
that these things are
independent of each other.
When you have a probability
model, you say they're
statistically independent
of each other.
OK, so that's the relationship
between the real world and the
models that we're dealing
with all the time.
We call it independence
in both cases.
But it means somewhat different
things in the two
situations.
OK, next about IID
random variables.
What are they?
Well, the joint distribution
function has to be equal to
the product of the individual
distribution functions.
You notice I've done something
funny here, which is a
convention I always use.
A lot of people use it.
If you have a bunch of
independent random variables,
they all have the same
distribution function.
If they all have the same
distribution function, it gets
confusing to refer to their
distribution functions as a
distribution function of
the random variable x1,
the random variable x2.
It's nicer to just take a
generic random variable x,
which has the same distribution
as all of these,
and express this numerically
in this way.
You have the same product form
for probability mass functions
and for density functions.
So this works throughout.
OK next, think about a
probability model in which r,
the set of real numbers,
is a sample space.
And x is some random variable
on that sample space.
Namely x then is a function from
the real numbers on to
the real numbers.
The interesting thing
here, and what I'm
saying here is obvious.
It's something that
you all know.
It's something that you've all
been using even before you
started to learn about
probability theory.
But at the same time, you
probably never thought about
it in a serious enough way that
you would really make
sense out of it.
You can always create an
extended probability model in
which the Cartesian space r to
the n-- in other words, the
space of n real numbers--
is the sample space.
And x1 to xn are independent
identity
distributed random variables.
This is not obvious.
And that's something
you have to prove.
But it's not hard to prove.
And all you have to do is start
out with a probability
model for one random variable.
And then just define all
products to be what they're
supposed to be and go from the
products to all unions and all
intersections.
We're just going to assume that
that's true because we
have to assume it's true if we
don't want to use any measure
theory here.
This is one of the easier
things to show
using measure theory.
But it's something you
are always used to.
When you think of a random
experiment, when you think of
playing dice with somebody
or playing cards with
someone, you are--
from the very beginning when you
started to talk about odds
or anything of that sort, you
have always had the idea that
this is a game which you
can play repeatedly.
And each time you play it,
it's the same game.
But the outcome is different.
But all the probabilities
are exactly the same.
What this says is you can always
make a probability
model that way.
You can always make a
probability model which
corresponds to what you've
always believed deep in your
hearts all your lives.
And fortunately, that's true.
Otherwise, you wouldn't
use probability.
OK, so let's move
on from that.
The page of philosophy, I will
stop doing that pretty soon.
But I have to get across what
the relationship is between
the real world and
these models that
we're dealing with.
Because otherwise, you as
engineers or business people
or financial analysts or
whatever the heck you're going
to become will start believing
in your probability models.
And you will cause untold damage
by losing track of the
fact that these are supposedly
models of something.
And you better think of
what they're supposed
to be models of.
OK, in order to do that, we're
going to study the sample
average, namely the sum of n
random variables divided by n.
That's the way you take
sample averages.
You add them all up.
You divide by n.
The law of large numbers, which
we're going to talk
about very soon, says that s
sub n over n essentially
becomes deterministic as
n becomes very large.
What we mean by that-- and most
of you have seen that in
various ways.
We will review it later today.
Well, we'll do it today
and on Wednesday.
And there's a big question
of about what becoming
deterministic means.
But there is an essential
idea there.
The extended model, namely
when you have one random
variable, you create a very
large number of them.
If it corresponds to repeated
experiments in the real world,
then s sub n over n corresponds
to the arithmetic
average in the real world.
In the real world, you do take
arithmetic averages.
Whenever you open up a
newspaper, somebody is taking
an arithmetic average of
something and says, gee, this
is significant.
This shows what's going
on someplace.
Models can have two types
of difficulties.
This paragraph is a little
different than what I wrote in
the handout because I realized
what I wrote in the handout
didn't make a whole
lot of sense.
OK, the two types of
difficulties you have with
models, especially when you're
trying to model things by IID
random variables.
In one, a sequence of real
world experiments is not
sufficiently similar and
isolated to each other to
correspond to the IID
extended model.
In other words, you want to
model things so that each
time, each trial of this
experiment, you do the same
thing but get a potentially
different answer.
Sometimes you rig things without
trying to do so in
such a way that these
experiments are not
independent of each other
and in fact are very,
very heavily biased.
You find people taking risk
models in the financial world
where they take all sorts
of these things.
And they say, oh, all right,
these things are all
independent of each other.
They look independent.
And then suddenly a
scare comes along.
And everybody sells
simultaneously.
And you find out that all these
random variables were
not independent at all.
They were very closely related
to each other but in a way you
never saw before.
OK, the other way that these
models are not true or not
valid is that the IID
extension is OK.
But the basic model
is not right.
OK, in other words,
you model a coin.
It's coming out heads with
probability 1/2.
And somebody has put
a loaded coin in.
And the probability that it
comes up heads is 0.45.
comes up tails is 0.55.
And you might guess that this
person always bets on tails
and tries to get you
to bet on heads.
So in that case, the basic
model that you're
using is not OK.
So you have both of these
kinds of problems.
You should try to keep
them straight.
But we'll learn about these
problems through
study of the models.
Namely, we're not going to go
through an enormous amount of
study on how you can bias a coin
or things of this sort.
OK, science, symmetry,
analogies, earlier models, all
of these are used to model
real world situations.
Let me again talk about an
example I talked about a
little bit last time because the
model was so trivial that
you probably understood
everything about the model in
the situation.
But you didn't understand what
it was illustrating.
You have two dice.
One of them is red.
And one of them is white.
You roll them.
By symmetry, each one comes up
to be 1, 2, 3, up to 6, each
with equal probability.
If you roll them with two hands
or something, they're
going to be independent
of each other.
And therefore, the probability
of each pair of outcomes--
red is equal to i.
White is equal to j.
Probability of each one of
those is going to be 136
because that's the size
of the sample space.
Now you take two white dice.
And you roll them.
What's the sample space?
Well, as far as the real world
is concerned, you can't
distinguish a red 1 from
a white 1 and a white
2 from a red 2.
In other words, those two
possibilities can't be
distinguished.
So you might say I want to
use a sample space which
corresponds to the--
what's the word I used here?--
finest grain possible outcome
that you can observe.
And who would do that?
You'd be crazy to do that.
I mean, you have a nice model
of rolling dice where each
outcome has probability 136.
And you would replace that
with something where the
probability of a 1, 1 is 136.
But the probability of a 1, 2 is
1/18 because you can get a
2 in two different ways.
You get a 2 in two different
ways, which says you're really
thinking about a red die
and a white die.
Otherwise, you wouldn't
be able to say that.
So the appropriate model here is
certainly to think in terms
of a red die and a white die.
It's what everybody does.
They just don't talk about it.
OK, so the point that I'm trying
to make here is that
what you call a finest grain
model is not at all clear.
And if it's not at all clear in
the case of dice, it sure
as hell is not clear in most of
the kinds of problems you
want to deal with.
So you need something
considerably more than that.
OK, so neither the axioms
nor experimentation
motivate this model.
In other words, you really
have to use common sense.
You have to use judgment.
And all of you have that.
It's just that by learning
all this mathematics, you
eventually start to think that
maybe you shouldn't use your
common sense.
So I have to keep saying that
no, you keep on using your
common sense.
You want to learn what these
models are about.
You want to use your
common sense also.
And you've got to go back and
forth between the two of them.
OK, that's almost the end
of our philosophy.
I guess one more slide.
I'm getting tired
of this stuff.
Comparing models for similar
situations and analyzing
limited and effective
models helps a lot
in clarifying fuzziness.
But ultimately, as in
all of science, some
experimentation is needed.
This is like any other
branch of science.
You need experimentation
sometimes.
You don't want to do too much of
it because you'd always be
doing experiments.
But the important thing is
that the outcome of an
experiment is a sample point.
It's not a probability.
You do an experiment.
You get an outcome.
And all you find is one sample
point, if you do the
experiment once.
And there's nothing that
lets you draw a
probability from that.
The only way you can get things
that you would call
probabilities is to use an
extended model, hope the
extended model corresponds to
the physical situation, and
deal with these law of large
numbers kind of things.
You don't necessarily need
IID random variables.
But you need something that you
know about between a large
number of random variables
to get from an outcome to
something you could reasonably
call a probability.
OK, so that's enough.
Let's go on to the law
of large numbers.
Let's do it in pictures first.
So you can lie back and relax
for a minute or stop being
bored by all this stuff.
What I've done here is to take
the simplest random variable I
can think of, which as
you might guess is a
binary random variable.
It's either 0 or 1.
Here it's 1 with probability
1/4 and 0
with probability 3/4.
I have actually calculated
these things.
The distribution function of
x1 plus x2 plus x3 plus x4,
this point down here,
is the probability
of all 0's, I guess.
And then you get the probability
of all 0's plus 1,
1 and so forth.
Here's where you take the sum
of 20 random variables.
And you're looking at the
distribution function of the
number of 1's that you get.
And it comes out like this.
Here you're looking at s50.
You're adding up 50
random variables.
And what's happening as far
as the gross picture
is concerned here?
Well, the mean value of s sub
n is the mean of a sum of
random variables.
And that's equal to n times
a mean of a single random
variable when you have
identically distributed random
variables or random variables
that have the same mean.
The variance is equal to
n times sigma squared.
Namely, when you take the
expected value of this
quantity squared, all these
cross terms are going to
balance out with the
mean when you do.
I mean, all of you know how to
find the variance of s sub n.
I hope you know how
to find that.
And when you do that,
it increases with n.
And the mean increases with n.
The standard deviation, which
gives you a picture of how
wide the distribution is,
only goes up as the
square root of n.
This is really the essence of
the weak law of large numbers.
I mean, everything else is
mathematical detail.
And then if you go on beyond
this and you talk about the
sample average, namely the sum
of these n random variables--
assume them IID again.
In fact, assume for this picture
that they're the same
binary random variables.
You look at the sample
average.
You find the mean of
the sample average.
And it's the mean of a single
random variable.
You find the variance of it.
Because of this n here and the
squaring that you're doing,
the variance of the sum divided
by n, the sigma
squared divided by n, what
happens as n gets large?
This variance goes to 0.
What happens when you have a
random variable, a sequence of
random variables, all of which
have the same mean and whose
standard deviation
is going to 0?
Well, you might play around with
a lot of funny kinds of
things that you might think
of as happening.
But essentially what's going
on here is the nice feature
that when you add all these
things up, the distribution
function gets scrunched
down into a unit step.
In other words, since the
standard deviation is going to
0, the sequence of random
variables--
since they all have
the same mean--
they all have smaller and
smaller standard deviations.
The only way you can do that is
to scrunch them down into a
limiting random variable,
which is deterministic.
And you can see that
happening here.
Namely the largest value is
the black thing, which is
getting smaller and smaller.
And the left side is
going that way.
On the right side, it's
So it looks like it's
approaching a unit step.
That has to be proven.
And there's a simple
proof of it.
And we'll see that.
And you've all seen
that before.
And you've all probably
said, ho-hum.
But that's the way it is.
Now the next thing to look at
for this same set of random
variables, the same sum, is
you look at the normalized
sum, namely sn minus
n times the mean.
And you divide that by the
square root of n times sigma.
And what do you get?
Well, every one of these
random variables--
for every n has mean 0, has mean
0 because the mean of sn
is n times x bar.
So you're subtracting off
of the mean essentially.
And every one of them
has variance 1.
So you've got a whole sequence
of random variables, which are
just sticking there at
the same mean, 0,
and at the same variance.
What's extraordinary when you
do that, and you can sort of
see this happening a little
bit, this curve looks like
it's going into a fixed
curve, which starts
out sticking to 0.
And then it gradually
comes up.
And it looks fairly smooth.
It goes off this way.
And if you read a lot about this
or if you think that all
respectable random variables are
Gaussian random variables,
and I hope at the end of this
course you will realize that
only most respectable
random variables are
Gaussian random variables.
There are many very interesting
random variables
that aren't.
But what the central limit
theorem says is that as you
add up more and more random
variables and you look at this
normalized sum here, what you
get is in fact the normal
distribution, which is this
strange integral here, that e
to the minus x squared
over 2 times the x.
Now what I want to do with the
rest of our time is to show
you why in fact that happens.
I've never seen this proof
of the central
limit theorem before.
I'm sure that some people
have done it.
I'm only going to do it for
the case of a binomial
distribution, which is the only
place where this works.
But I think in doing this you
will see why in fact that
strange e to the minus x squared
over 2 comes up.
It sure is not obvious by
looking at this problem.
OK, so that's what we're
going to do.
And I'm hoping that after you
see this, you will in fact
understand why the central limit
theorem is true as well
as knowing that it's true.
OK, so let's look at the
Bernoulli process.
You have a sequence of binary
random variables, each of them
is IID, each of them is
1 with probability p.
And a 0 with probability
q equals 1 minus p.
You add them all up.
They're IID.
And the question is, what
does the distribution of
the sum look like?
Well, it has a nice
formula to it.
It's that formula down there.
You've probably seen that
formula before.
Let's get some idea
of where it comes
from and what it means.
Each n tuple that starts with
k1's and then ends with n
minus k0's, each one of those
has the same probability.
And it's p to the k times
q to the n minus k.
In other words, the probability
you get a 1 on the
first toss is p.
The probability you get a 1 on
the second toss also, since
those are independent,
probability you get two 1's in
a row is p squared.
Probably you get three 1's
in a row is p cubed and
so forth up to k.
Because we're looking at the
probability that the first k
outputs are 1, so the
probability of
that is p to the k.
That's this term.
And the probability that the
rest of them are all 0's is q
to the n minus k.
And this is sometimes confusing
to you because you
often think that this is going
to be maximized when k is
equal to p over n.
You have some strange view of
the law of large numbers.
Well no, this quantity--
if p is less than 1/2, it's
going to be largest at k
equals zero.
The most probable single outcome
from n tosses of a
coin, and it's a biased
coin, it comes out 1's
more often than 0's.
0's are more probable
than 1's.
The most probable output
is all 0's.
Very improbable, but that's the
most probable of all these
improbable things.
But as you probably know
already, there are n choose k
different n tuples, all of which
have k1's in them and n
minus k0's.
If you don't know that,
I didn't even
put that in the text.
I put most things there.
This is one of those basic
combinatorial facts.
Look it up in Wikipedia.
You'll probably get a cleaner
explanation of it there than
anywhere else.
But look it up in any elementary
probability book or
in any elementary combinatorics
book.
I'm sure that all of you
have seen this stuff.
So when you put this together,
the probability that the sum
of a n random variables, all
of which are binary, the
probability of getting k1's is
n choose k times p to the k
times q to the n minus k.
Now you look at that.
And if k is 1,000 and if n is
1,000, I mean, your eyes
boggle because you can't
imagine what that
number looks like.
So we want to find out
what it looks like.
And here's a tricky
way of doing it.
What we want to do is to see
how this varies with k.
And in particular, we want to
see how it varies with k when
n is very large and when k is
relatively close to p times n.
So what we're going to do
is take the ratio of the
probability of k plus 1 1's
to the ratio of k1's.
And what is that?
I've written it out.
n choose k, n choose
k plus 1--
which is this term here--
is n factorial divided by k plus
1 factorial times n minus
k minus 1 factorial.
This term here--
you put the n factorial down
on the bottom, k factorial
times n minus k quantity
factorial.
And then you take the
p's and the q's.
For this term here you have p
to the k plus 1 q to the n
minus k minus 1.
And for this one here you
have p to the k times p
to the n minus k.
All that stuff cancels out,
which is really cute.
When you look at this term you
have p to the k plus 1
over p to the k.
That's just p.
And here you have q to the
n minus k minus 1 over q
to the n minus k.
That's just q in the
denominator.
So this goes into p over q.
This quantity here is almost
a simple n factorial over n
factorial is 1.
k plus 1 factorial divided by
k factorial is k plus 1.
That's this term here.
And the n minus k over n minus
k minus 1 is n minus k.
So this ratio here
is just that very
simple expression there.
Now this ratio is strictly
decreasing in k.
How do I see that?
Well, as k gets bigger and
bigger, what happens?
As k gets bigger, the numerator
gets larger.
The denominator--
excuse me, as k gets larger,
the numerator gets smaller.
The denominator gets larger.
So the ratio of the
two gets smaller.
So this whole quantity here,
as k gets larger and larger
for fixed n, is just decreasing
and decreasing and
decreasing.
Now let's look a little bit at
where this crosses 1, if it
does cross 1.
And what I claim here is that
when k plus 1 is less than or
equal to pn, what
happens here?
Well if I can do this--
I usually get confused
doing these things.
But if k plus 1 is less than
or equal to pn, this is the
last of these choices here, then
k is also less than or
equal to pn.
And therefore, n minus
k is greater than--
in fact, k is strictly
less than pn.
And n minus k is strictly
greater than n minus pn.
And since q is 1 minus
p, this is n times q.
OK, so you take this
divided by this.
And you take this
And sure enough, this ratio
here is greater than 1 any
time you have a k which is
smaller than what you think k
ought to be, which
is p over n.
OK, so you have these three
quantities here.
Let me go on to the
next slide.
Since these ratios are less
than 1 when k is large,
approximately equal to 1 when k
is close to pn, and greater
than 1 when it's smaller than
1, if I plot these things,
what I find is that as k is
increasing, getting closer and
closer to pn, it's getting
larger and larger.
As k is increasing further,
getting larger than pn, this
ratio says that these
things have to be
getting smaller and smaller.
So just from looking at this, we
know that these terms have
to be increasing for terms less
than pn and have to be
decreasing for terms
greater than pn.
So this is a bell-shaped
curve.
We've already seen that.
It might not be quite clear that
it's bell-shaped in the
sense that it kind of tapers
off as you get smaller.
Because these ratios are getting
bigger and bigger, as
k gets bigger and bigger, the
ratio of this term to this
term gets bigger and bigger.
So what's happening there?
As this ratio gets bigger and
bigger, these terms get
smaller and smaller.
But as these terms get smaller
and smaller, they're getting
closer and closer to 0.
So even though they're going to
0 like a bat out of hell,
they still can't get
any smaller than 0.
So they just taper down and
start to get close to 0.
So that is roughly how
this sum of binary
random variables behave.
OK, so let's go on and show that
the central limit theorem
holds for the Bernoulli
process.
And that's just as
easy really.
There's nothing more difficult
about it that we
have to deal with.
This ratio, as we've said, is
equal to n minus k over k plus
1 times p over k.
What we're interested
in here--
I mean, we've already seen from
the last slide that the
interesting thing here
is the big terms.
And the big terms are the terms
which are close to pn.
So what we'd like to do is look
at values of k which are
close to pn.
What I've done here is to plot
this as k minus the integer
value of pn.
So we get integers.
What I'm going to assume now,
because this gets a little
hairy if I don't do that, I'm
going to assume that pn is
equal to an integer.
It doesn't make a whole lot of
difference to the argument.
It just leaves out a lot
of terms that you don't
have to play with.
So we'll assume that
pn is an integer.
With this example, we're
looking at where
p is equal to 1/4.
Pn is going to be an integer
whenever n is a multiple of 4.
So things are fine then.
If I try to make p equal to 1
over pi, then that doesn't
work so well.
But after all, no reason to
chose p in such a strange way.
OK, so I'm going to look at this
for a fixed value of n.
I'm going to look at it as k
increases for k less than pn.
I'm going to look at it
as it decreases for k
greater than pn.
And I'm going to define k to
be equal to the i plus pn.
So I'm going to put the whole
thing in terms of
i instead of k.
OK, so when I substitute i
equals k minus pn for k here,
what I'm going to get
is this term.
It's going to be the probability
of pn plus i plus
1 over p of--
fortunately when you're using
textures, you can distinguish
different kinds of p's.
I have too many p's
in this equation.
This is the probability
mass function.
This is just my probability
of a 1.
And p's are things that you
like to use a lot in
probability.
So it's nice to have that
separation there.
OK, when I take this and I
substitute it into that with k
equal to i, what I get is
n minus pn minus i.
That's n minus k over pn plus
i plus 1 times p over q.
Fair enough, OK, all I'm doing
is replacing k with pn plus i
because I want i to be very
close to 0 in this argument.
Because I've already seen that
these terms are only
significant when i is relatively
close to 0.
Because when I get away from 0,
these terms are going down
very, very fast.
So when I do that,
what do I get?
I get n minus pn
is equal to qn.
That's nice.
So I have an nq here.
I have a q here.
I have a pn here.
I have a p here.
I'm going to multiply
this p by n.
this q by n.
And I'm going to take a ratio
of this pair of things.
So when I take this ratio,
I'm going to get nq over
nq, which is 1.
And the other terms there
become minus i over nq.
In the denominator, I'm going to
divide pn plus i plus 1 by
p, by pn, which gives me 1 plus
i plus 1 divided by np.
So I get two terms, ratio of
two terms, which are both
close to 1 at this point and
which are getting closer and
closer to 1 as n gets
larger and larger.
Now let's take the logarithm
of this.
Let me justify taking the
logarithm of it in two
different ways.
One of them is that what
we're trying to prove--
and I'm playing the game
that all of you
always play in quizzes.
When you're trying to prove
something, what do you do?
You start at the beginning.
You work this way.
You start at the end.
You work back this way.
And you hope, at some point, the
two things come together.
If they don't come together,
you get to this point.
And you say, obviously.
And then you go to that point
which leads to-- yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, so I'm doing
the same thing here.
This probability that we're
trying to calculate--
well, I've listed it
here in terms of--
I have put it here in terms of
a distribution function.
I will do just as well if I can
do it in terms of an PMF.
And what I'd like to show is
that the PMF of sn minus nX
bar over square root of n
times sigma is somehow
proportional to e to the
minus x squared over 2.
Now if I want to do that, it
will be all right if I can
take the logarithm of this
term and show that
it's a square nX.
And if I want to show that this
logarithm is a square nX,
and I'm looking at the
differentials at each time,
what are the differentials going
to be if the sum of the
differentials is quadratic?
If the sum of these
differentials is quadratic,
then the individual terms
have to be linear.
If I take a bunch of linear
terms, if I add up 1 plus 2
plus 3 plus 4 plus 5, you've
all done this I'm sure.
And down here you write n plus
n minus 1 plus, plus 1.
And what do you get?
You get n times n
plus 1 over 2.
You can also approximate
that by integrating.
Whenever you add up a sum
of linear terms, you
get a square term.
And I'm just curious.
How many of you have
seen that?
Good, OK.
Well, it's only about 1/2.
So it's something you've
probably seen in high school.
Or your haven't seen
it at all.
So let's go on with
this argument.
OK, so I'm going to take
the logarithm of
this expression here.
I'm going to take
the logarithm.
I'm going to have the logarithm
of 1 minus i over nq
minus the logarithm of 1
plus i plus 1 over np.
And I'm going to use what I
think of as one of the most
useful inequalities that you
will ever see, which is the
natural log of 1 plus x.
If we use a power expansion, we
get x minus x squared over
2 plus x cubed over 3 minus--
it's an alternating series.
If x is negative, this
term is negative.
This term is negative.
And all this makes sense
because if I draw this
function here, logarithm of
1 plus x at x equals 0.
This is equal to 0.
It comes up with a slope of 1.
And it levels off.
And here it's going
down very fast.
So these terms, you get
these negative terms.
And on the positive side, you
get these alternating terms.
So this goes up slowly,
down fast.
The slope here is x, which
is this term here.
The curvature here gives you
the minus x squared over 2.
And the approximation, which is
very useful here, is that
the logarithm of 1 plus x, when
x is small, is equal to x
plus what we call
little l of x.
Namely something which goes
to 0 faster than x
as x goes to 0.
OK, all of you know
that, right?
Well, if you don't know
it, now you know it.
It's useful.
You will use it again
and again.
OK, so what we're
going to do is--
well, that's pretty good.
Where did I get to that point?
I skipped something.
What I have shown is that this
increment in the probability,
in the PMF for s sub n, namely
the increment as you increase
i by 1, is linear in i.
And in fact, the logarithm of
this increment is linear in i.
So therefore, by what I was
saying before, the logarithm
of the actual terms should be
rather than linear in i, they
should be quadratic in i.
So that's what I'm trying
to do here.
I just missed this
whole term here.
What I'm interested in now is
getting a handle on pn plus
some larger value,
j, divided by the
probability of sn for pn.
What am I trying to do here?
I should've said what
I was trying to do.
This term is just one term.
It's fixed.
Be nice if we knew what it was,
we don't at the moment.
But I'm trying to express
everything else in terms of
that one unknown term.
And what I'm trying to do is to
show that the logarithm of
this everything else is going
to be quadratic in j.
And if I can do that, then I
only have one undetermined
factor in this whole sum.
And I can use the fact that PMF
summed to 1 to solve the
whole problem.
So I'm going to express the
probability that we get pn
plus j1's divided by the
probability that we get pn1's.
It's the sum of the probability
pn plus i plus 1
over pn plus i.
And we increase i.
We start out at i equals 0.
And then the denominator is
probability of pn plus 0,
which is this term.
And each time we increase i by
1, this term cancels out with
the previous or the next
value of this term.
And when I get all done, all I
have is this expression here.
Everybody see that?
OK, I see a lot of--
if you don't see it,
just look at it.
And you'll see that this--
I think you'll see
that this works.
OK, so now I take this
expression here.
This logarithm is this
linear term here.
What do I want to do?
I want to sum i from
0 up to j minus 1.
What do I get when I sum
i from 0 to j minus 1?
I get this expression here.
I get j times j minus
1 divided by 2n.
Oh, I was--
I skipped something.
Let's go back a little bit.
Because it'll look like
it was a typo.
When I took this logarithm and
I applied this approximation
to it, I got minus i over nq
minus i over np minus 1 over
np plus square terms in n.
When I take i over nq minus i
over np, I can combine those
two things together.
I can take ip over npq
minus iq times npq.
And q plus p is equal to 1.
So the numerator
all goes away.
And these two terms combine to
be minus i over n times p
times p times q.
And I just has this one last
little term left here.
Don't know what to
do with that.
But then I add up
all these terms.
This one is the one that
leads to j times j
minus 1 over 2 npq.
This one is the one that
leads to j over np.
And I just neglect this term,
which is negligible compared
to j squared.
I get minus j squared
over 2 npq.
Let me come back later to say
why I'm so eager to neglect
this term except that that's
what I have to do if I want to
get the right answer.
OK, so we'll see why that has
to be negligible in just a
little bit.
But now this logarithm is coming
out to be exactly the
term that I want it to be.
So finally, the logarithm of
the sum of these random
variables pn plus j, namely j
off the mean, divided by that
if pn is equal to minus j
squared over 2 npq plus some
negligible terms.
And this says when I
exponentiate things, that the
probability that sn is j off
the mean is approximately
equal to this term, the
probability that it's right at
the mean, times e to the minus
j squared over 2 npq.
What that is saying is that this
sum of terms that I was
looking at before--
this term here, this term, this
term, this term, this
term, and so forth down--
these terms here are actually
going as minus j squared over
2 npq, which is what they should
be going as if you have
a Gaussian curve here.
OK, now there's one other thing
we have to do, which is
figure out what this term is.
And if you look at this as an
undetermined coefficient on
these Gaussian-type terms and
you think of what happens if I
sum this over all i, well, if
I sum it over all i what I'm
going to get is the sum of all
of these terms here, which are
negligible except where j
squared is proportional to n.
So I don't have to sum them
beyond the point where this
approximation makes sense.
So I want to sum all
these terms.
In summing these terms, when n
gets very, very large, these
things are dropping off
very, very slowly.
The curve is getting
very, very wide.
If i scrunch the curve back in
again, what I get is a Riemann
approximation to a normal
density curve.
Therefore, I can integrate it.
And believe me.
If you don't believe me,
I'll go through it.
And you won't like that.
When you go through this, what
you get is in fact this
expression right here, which
says that when n gets very,
very large and j is the offset
from the mean and is
proportional to--
well, it's proportional to
the square root of n.
Then what I get is this PMF
here, which is in fact what
the central limit
theorem says.
And now if you go back and try
to think of exactly what we've
done, what we've done is to
show that the logarithm of
these differences here is
in fact linear in i.
Therefore, when you sum them,
you get something which is
quadratic in j.
And because of that, all you
have to do is normalize with a
center term.
And you get this.
The central limit theorem,
especially for the binary
case, is almost always done
by using a Stirling
approximation.
And a Stirling approximation is
one of these things which
is black magic.
I don't know any place except in
William Feller's book where
anyone talks about where this
formula comes from.
If you now go back and look
very carefully at this
derivation, this tells
you what the Stirling
approximation is.
Because if you do this for p
equals q, what you're doing is
actually evaluating n choose
k where k is very
close to and over 2.
And that will tell you exactly
what Stirling's
approximation has to be.
In other words, that's a way
of deriving Stirling's
approximation.
The very backward way of
doing things it seems.
But often backward ways
are the best ways
of doing these things.
OK, so I told you I
would stop at some
point and ask for questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you please go
back one slide before this
slide where can you neglect
a term, which [INAUDIBLE],
minus j over np.
PROFESSOR: Why did I neglect
the j over np?
OK, that's a good question.
If you look at this curve here,
and I put the j in.
I can put the j in by just
making this expression here
look at one smaller value of
j or one larger value of j.
And you get something different
whether you're
looking at the minus side
or the plus side.
In fact, if p is equal to q,
this term cancels out.
If p is not equal to q, what
happens is that the central
limit theorem is approximately
symmetric.
But in this first ordered term,
it's not quite symmetric.
It can't be symmetric because
this is p times n.
And you have all these
terms out to 1.
And you have many, many
fewer terms back to 0.
So it has to be slightly
asymmetric.
But it's only asymmetric over at
most a unit of value here,
which is not significant.
Because as n gets bigger,
these terms--
well, as I've done
it, the terms do
not get close together.
But if I want to think of it
as a normalized Gaussian
curve, I have to make the
terms close together.
So that extra term is
not significant.
I wish I had a nicer way of
taking care of all the
approximations here.
I haven't put this in the notes
because I still haven't
figured out how to do that.
But I still think you get more
insight from doing it this way
than you do by going through
Stirling's approximation, all
those pages and pages
of algebra.
Anything else?
OK, well, see you
Wednesday then.